hello and welcome in this video
i explain to you what dummy variables
are
and how you can easily create them
online
and we get started right now let us
first talk about categorical variables
in a regression model categorical
variables with two characteristics can
be used as
independent variables also called
predictors
categorical variables are either nominal
or ordinal variables categorical
variables
with two expressions are also called
dichotomous an example would be gender
with the categories male and female
let's say you coded female as zero
and male as one in that case
female would be the reference category
if we now look at the regression
equation and say the variable
x1 is gender then b1
is the regression coefficient for gender
so the question now is
how can we interpret b1 we said that
zero is female and one is male
so we just put that in then we have
zero times b1 for a female person
and one time b1 for a male person
accordingly b1 indicates the difference
between male
and female let's say in this example we
want to predict the
income of a person so y would be
our income if a person is male
this person earns more by the amount of
b1
than a woman therefore b1
is the salary difference between men and
women
now we have discussed how to handle
variables with two characteristics
now let's take a look at what we do when
we have a variable
with more than two characteristics let's
look at an example
in this example we want to predict the
fuel consumption of a car
based on its horsepower and the vehicle
type and let's say there are only three
vehicle types sedan sports car
and familyvan thus we have a variable
vehicle type with more than two
characteristics
in a regression however we can only
consider
categorical variables with two
characteristics
therefore the question now is what
should we do
in order to use categorical variables
with more than two characteristics in a
regression model
we have to create dummy variables
this means that we simply create three
new variables each new variable
has two characteristics these
characteristics
are 0 and 1 or yes
and no so in our example we have our
vehicle type
with the characteristics see then
sportscar
and familyvan now we create one
new variable out of each characteristic
so this means we create one variable
which says
is it a sea then yes or no
is it a sports car yes or no
and finally is it a family van yes or no
so before we had one variable
now we have three variables which are
dichotomous
and therefore have only two
characteristics
and these three new variables can be
used in our regression model now
so what does that mean for your data
preparation now
you originally have one column with the
vehicle type
where the individual vehicles from your
sample are listed
the first is the sea then the second is
also a sedan the third is the sports car
and so on and so forth out of this table
you create your new three variables now
so the question is what is the first car
is it a sea then so you put a one
here and a zero for the other cars
because it is not a sports car and it is
not
a family van the second car is also a
sedan
so we'll put a one here and the third
one
is a sports car so we'll put the one in
the column sports car
and the zero for the other car types
so with this procedure we finally formed
our dummy variables now there's still
one
important thing to note the number of
dummy variables formed
is always the number of characteristics
minus one with this two variables
we have the whole information and we do
not need
a third variable if we know that zidane
is one
we also know that family van is zero
and if we know that sedan is zero
and sports car is zero we know that
familyvan is
one and now i will show you how you can
create
the dummy variables online with data tab
in order to do this please visit
datadept.net
and click on the statistics calculator
if you want to use your own data
just click on clear table i will use the
example data now
further if you want to perform a
regression analysis
you choose the tab regression
on the left side you can choose your
dependent variable
on the right side you can choose your
independent variables
for our example we use salary as the
dependent variable
and for the independent variables we
choose h
and place of residence place of
residence
has three characteristics h is metric
if we scroll down now we can already see
the results
of the linear regression and in this
table
you can see that data tab automatically
creates the dummy variables for you
so we have the place of residence which
has
three characteristics and we can see
that
two dummy variables are created these
two dummy variables are chicago
and new york if your dependent variable
is categorical
and you want to perform a regression you
need to calculate a logistic regression
if you want to find out what a logistic
regression is
just check out my next video see you
soon
you